all eyes were once more on arguably this
city's most compelling building sin
Mark's Basilica sits at Venice's lowest
point and the fear was more flooding
could again threaten a structure which
had already been breached by water we
were taken in and downwards to the
basilica's oldest point the Crypt where
the tombs of Archbishop's going back
centuries rest every one of them was
submerged underwater after a near record
high tide
earlier this week again but it has
happened again
Italy's Culture Minister tweeting these
images saying no words are necessary for
what's happening in Venice just these
pictures from some marks parts of the
Basilica were flooded for a second time
this week after a Hittite which peaked
at one point five four meters strong
winds and rain had made for a toxic mix
in the morning leaving some marks square
near desolate save for a few
businesspeople battling to protect their
premises you'll find remarkably
philosophical people in Venice some told
us we live with the water our ancestors
the generations before us experienced
flooding but most will point to the fact
this is 2019 when they say scenes like
this should be preventable there's no
business being done at Giorgio penso
store today close to the Basilica it's
also under water he's angry a flood
defense system which has been years in
the making is still not up and running
yamazaki City I don't quite get going to
reboot okay maybe we hope that the
government would give us some money at
least to repair the first damages only
that and hoping they can then help us
even further the square and its
inhabitants were not the only casualties
in Street after Street businesses
camping out and drawing sympathy from
visitors who found themselves in the
middle of the deluge this family from
the UK were trying to make the best of
the conditions it's hard for us but it's
harder for them I mean they must be
losing a lot of trades oh yeah
definitely everywhere we're trying to go
in everywhere shot the Italian
government has declared a state of
emergency here freeing up tens of
millions of euros to help repair the
city but what so many want is investment
to ensure this doesn't happen again
Michelle Clifford Sky News Venice Italy